Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah. Let's begin.
Okay.
So we are continuing on with swords of X and in this video we're picking up with
X-Force. Yes we are. And the continuation of this battle.
So the swords of X event, it gets a little wonky here, right?
Like I always thought it would actually be a duel with swords,
like strictly with swords.
Apparently that's not really the case at the start of this whole thing.
The score is a Rocco five cacoa three. We ended up having a Rocco, getting,
getting a six point. Then they get a seventh point.
Then they get an eighth point. Agricola just keeps falling behind.
And it's these various weird and wonky competitions, right?
Like who can push a Boulder up a Hill or like who can,
who can basically out swim monsters and survive. Ah,
you have an eating contest where you get foods from the cricket world.
There's a dance off, which apparently a cipher does amazingly well. Right.
He absolutely crushes it. So he gets a point on there.
It's like Penrose steps that they have to navigate through. Uh,
they have to put together a puzzle, right.
So like Precoa gets a win on that because I guess the forces of Morocco,
aren't the sharpest tool in the shed. We,
the way it was had to be dominant because it was forces from the same side,
but then like you end up having a runway walk off, which I didn't even know.
That was really like, I guess it was a contest in terms of like, I don't,
I don't know. I don't really do runways.
I know there's a show about runways anyway, storm crushes it. Right.
And a lot of that's attributed to the fact that it's because she might be drunk,
but like consistently across the board,
they're just kind of like these wonky and goofy competitions. Right.
They're just sort of weird and almost nonsensical.
The other thing about this is that you ended up having Brian Bradick,
who's still kind of continuing on he's within the crooked market itself and kind
of continuing on and a little, uh,
still a little approached about the fact that like Betsy Braddock's basically
debt, right?
And so you end up having him met by Saturday and Saturday and who again,
refers to him as captain Britain.
He basically disregards that says I'm not captain Britain. Don't call me that.
She ultimately says like the title is yours.
And if you won't come around to being captain Britain willingly,
then fury will work. Right.
And she basically seems to have the Fury's at our back. Now,
one of the other things that goes on here and is something that I'm not a
hundred percent sure I'm on the fence about is you have Jim Jasper's
encountering captain Britain again,
but captain Britain doesn't really seem to give any indication that he knows who
he is. And it would have been a cool little, a cool little nod, um,
in the sense that you, you would have Jim Jasper is like,
it's good to see you again, captain, I'm sorry. Things ended so weird last time,
but you know, you tried to kill me and everything.
It would have been cool to see that by just kind of a little reference to the
cricket world from back in the day, it may be that it's just kind of like,
you know, mobile doesn't really care or Hickman doesn't really care.
I don't really know, but it would've been a cool little nod, you know, to see,
because I love that story so much.
And I love the character of Jim Jasper's because he's just so broken and
overpowered.
You end up having this thing where it's basically a race between red root and
Brian Bradick and red root is of course more or less a shrub and she's super
slow. But in the midst of all this, when, when, uh, when Madam Jasper says like,
you'll be able to find the finish line around here somewhere, right?
If you look hard enough, you can find anything in a cricket market,
including a finish line.
Once the gunfire goes off and Brian Braddock starts running,
he's immediately set upon by these Fury's right.
These fairies all immediately go after him because it's basically Saturday
working against the we're against Brian Braddock and the forces of Kakowa
because Brian Radek basically won't be her guy, right.
He just won't go with her. Right. He just refuses to bend the knees,
so to speak and to, you know, be the,
whatever it is that Saturday and wants out of him. Right. A concubine.
I don't know. I don't really know.
Regardless red root basically begins a process of just kind of, of,
of passing them up. And of course, she's kind of walking in walking,
but she ends up bumping into this table and shatters a crystal that happens to
land at the foot of Jim Jasper's and just kind of says,
everything has a cost of the market, right. Everything. Now, of course,
she continues on blissfully unaware of what's happening.
And then ultimately crosses the finish line,
which is something like five feet away from them now, Saturday.
And of course does this just for the sake of giving the point to a Rocco, right?
So it is again like the, the contest is basically rig,
but we're grind Bradick is basically subdued.
Jim Jaspers starts talking to red root and says, okay, so like,
now there's the matter of your debt? And she's like, what are you talking about?
He's like, you shattered a crystal, right? This rare crystal idle of Bombay,
right? Crafted from assault of an Oompa Ghanian, princesses tears.
I don't really know what that is, but he's basically like it was priceless,
right? Everything here has a price. If you break something that's priceless,
you have to deal with it accordingly.
And so visually with the whole process being done and sat our,
sending the Fury's away,
which is also a little bit disappointed that Brian brag doesn't recognize who
they are. That in turn,
Jim Jaspers uses his ability to manipulate reality and shrinks red root down.
And encases her in glass and leaves her there.
Like she's literally just kind of stuck there,
forevermore seemingly never to be able to escape.
And so with that being the case,
you in turn have a Saturday who basically says like you have done untold damage
to the crooked market, right? I mean,
there's no calculating how much damage you've done here.
Everything here is irreplaceable, right?
So if red root was shrunk down for what she did,
God only knows what Jim Jasper is going to do to you.
Unless of course you asked for my help. If you ask for my help,
then Jim Jasper's won't do anything to you now,
whether or not that's what he did. We're not given a definitive answer to.
Instead,
what we ended up doing is switching over to these two interesting scenarios that
go on in terms of part of this contest, right?
The first one comes in the form of magic where she has to answer a riddle.
If she gets the answer, right. Uh, then of course she gets a point.
If she gets a wrong, then she loses, right? So the riddle is a white rabbit,
pulled out of a black top hat and a spell cast by a wizard and the very life
force of Saturday. What am I? And she basically says,
that's an easy one magic and it's spelled mag. I K and she's wrong.
So she got that one wrong because she's an idiot. But with, with Wolverine and,
uh, and, and white sword is a little bit different.
They have to stand in front of a mirror and they have to observe the faces of
all the people they've killed. The first one to look away,
loses the first one to blink loses Wolverine actually ends up crying and ends up
blinking. Now,
this is designed to kind of compare these two characters between each other,
the white sword relishes, and loves the idea of battle.
And doesn't really care much about the people that he's taking out with
Wolverine.
It's a wholly different beast because the people that he's lost in some ways
have actually been a result of his own actions.
Specifically his wife dying this son of Daikin, right?
She died partially because of Wolverine's actions himself, right.
He kind of led to that situation, taking place,
the people that saber-tooth killed over the course of his life,
like his actions inevitably seem to lead to that. And so, because of that,
like he, you know, a lot of the, the losses,
he sustained have been a defining part of his character,
but also crushed them at the same time.
And so that's why Wolverine ends up being the first to blink Wolverine loses.
So the score now stands a Rocco 15 cacoa five, right?
They're getting absolutely decimated and things only really seem to get worse.
Right? They have these things called the rock silence of a,
of clever more that nobody that almost no one can really resist their call and
Gorgon goes running up on it. Right. Just gets naked,
starts taking his clothes off. Like, yeah, man, me and the rocks,
we're going to get it on. And then from there,
you ended up switching over to Merlin who presents a challenge to the horseman
war and to captain Britain and says, your challenge is to kill the kit.
That's your task. And like war just immediately goes to kill it. And Brian,
Braddock's like, no, you can't kill that. Kitten.
That bite that in that moment is basically him acquiescing.
It's showing you wouldn't do it quick. Whoah loses. Right?
So a Rocco 17 cook hoe up five, and that's kind of how these things continue.
But then you pick up with storm and you pick up with the horsemen of death.
And the two of them real storm really kind of seems to come to you after having
been intoxicated, right. Having been drunk.
And they brought to the realm of Sevilla, right? Kind of like this,
this realm of vampires and so on. And the contest is again,
basically a fight to the death. And we're storm initially says, no,
we need to postpone this because something's wrong with me,
whatever it was that I had at that bar of a, of Jim Jasper's,
I'm effectively drunk. Now the response of death is, I mean, no, but I mean,
you can, but if you do, then you'll have to forfeit.
And that's when she realizes he intentionally did this to her, right.
He got her drunk sacker power.
And now like she's going to have to fight in traditional hand-to-hand combat.
The thing about this though is storm is no Slack.
And she's also one of the best fighters and Marvel, not the best,
best where she's not like in the top five or probably even the top 10,
but she's a really, really, really good fighter and able to hold her own.
And as she's fighting this conflict against, uh, against death,
she gets the upper hand and actually destroys his sword in the process.
And so in response to that,
death removes his helmet and he basically intends to use the death stare.
Now the death stare is basically those individuals who look upon it affectively
died, right? If you, if you glance, if you look at that, look into his face,
his stairwell kill you. Hence the reason why he was given the name death,
but he's not immune to his own powers. He's just highly resistant to them.
And this is,
this comes in the form that when he admits the death stare and that kind of
substance comes out and intends to kill storm,
she reflects it back out and using her sword because her sword is pristine and
it's basically a mirror.
And so it basically kind of incapacitates him for a moment.
She punches a sword through his chest and kills a horseman of death.
This of course leads to all the vampires, basically tearing them apart.
And the point goes to Coca-Cola. So at this point right now,
because the storm may manage to bounce back,
but they're still losing terribly right now. The score is 17.
A Rocco six took her COA,
no earthly clue how in the world they could possibly make that up.
That being said, guys, we're going to bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to comments,
explain and make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob
port. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all later. Bruce.
[Inaudible].